[Música]
economía aquí en directo América me
acompaña en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches comenzamos
hablando de un tema que me encanta
Aviación industria aérea los pilotos de
la aerolínea latam habían acordado ir a
huelga por un conflicto salarial con las
directivas en qué quedó eso bueno el 99%
de los miembros de este sindicato de
pilotos de lata marylands votó a favor
de iniciar la huelga pero luego llegaron
a un acuerdo con esta aerolínea los
pilotos pedían regresar a las
condiciones que tenían prepandemia los
detalles Sí y los tiene nuestra
corresponsal en Chile Patricia Luna
el sindicato de pilotos de latam alcanzó
un acuerdo en extremis minutos antes de
que se hubiera acabado el plazo que
ellos mismos habían puesto para evitar
una huelga que había sido convocada una
huelga de pilotos para el próximo jueves
el sindicato solicitaba a los dirigentes
de la aerolínea que restablecieran las
condiciones que los pilotos tenían
previo a la pandemia según el sindicato
se despidieron a 240 pilotos y se redujo
el sueldo en un 30% al resto de la
plantilla sin embargo estas condiciones
ya se habían restablecido en el caso de
los ejecutivos que volvieron a cobrar el
100% de sus sueldos y se pedían Lo mismo
para los pilotos es también una cuestión
de dignidad afirmaron desde el sindicato
en el que alabaron en la solidaridad que
mantuvieron los pilotos para acompañar a
la aerolínea en uno de sus peores
momentos históricos como ocurrió con
muchas otras aerolíneas en el mundo
durante la pandemia llegó a tener
suspendido un 95% de sus vuelos incluso
apeló al capítulo 11 de la ley de
quiebre de Estados Unidos un proceso que
acaba de culminar más después de dos
años y medio y que supuso la reducción
de su deuda en un
35%, Fueron momentos difíciles sin
embargo en octubre de este 2022 la tan
ya había recuperado un 80% de la
actividad respecto al año anterior y
restablecido muchas de las rutas que
unen las principales ciudades de América
Latina como sabemos latam es una de las
compañías de aerolíneas más importantes
de América Latina que realiza vuelos de
conexión con América Latina y el resto
del mundo hablemos ahora de Colombia la
empresa de petróleos de este país
ecopetrol anunció que nos seguirá con el
fracking en este país para extraer
petróleo esto en sintonía con la
política del gobierno bueno así lo
confirmó Santiago el ceo de esta
compañía Felipe bayón El señor de la
empresa dijo a los inversionistas que
pidieron a la agencia Nacional de
hidrocarburos la suspensión de los
contratos Por 90 días aunque dejó
abierta la posibilidad de sentarse con
el gobierno para discutir el tema
ecopetrol también anunció la suspensión
de contratos con Epson móvil estos
acuerdos relacionados con el fracking en
sintonía con las políticas del gobierno
la empresa reportó una utilidad neta de
9,5 billones de pesos colombianos en el
tercer trimestre de 2022 esto es un
crecimiento del 150% respecto al mismo
periodo pero del año pasado Ya hablemos
ahora de la Cumbre con 27 durante esta
Cumbre del clima se exigió más acciones
al sector privado lo van a lograr Bueno
uno de los principales asuntos en esta
Cup Es sobre la compensación a los
países más pobres por el daño causado
por el cambio climático este punto
denominado pérdidas y daños ha sido
primera vez incluido en la agenda de una
Cumbre climática los países más ricos se
han mostrado reacios a aceptar que
tienen responsabilidad por las emisiones
históricas y hasta el momento no han
brindado el nivel de apoyo que las
naciones en desarrollo dicen que
necesitan el asesor principal de la
dirección climática de la comisión
europea Jacob worksman defendió el apoyo
de la Unión Europea a financiar estos
daños y pérdidas hoy se presentó también
un informe en el que se pide el sector
privado que invierta aproximadamente 2,4
billones de dólares al año para 2030 que
necesitan los países emergentes y en
desarrollo para reducir las emisiones
aumentar la resiliencia y hacer frente a
las pérdidas y daños causados por los
efectos del cambio climático pasemos
ahora a hablar de Alemania porque el
ministro de finanzas de este país
rechazó una propuesta para subir los
impuestos a los más ricos en Alemania el
liberal de Christian Linden rechazó la
recomendaciones del Consejo asesor de
economistas del gobierno Alemán de subir
los tipos impositivos máximos y aplazar
la compensación del efecto de la
inflación sobre el impuesto sobre la
renta el ministro argumentó que sería
extremadamente peligroso apuntar a
posibles subidas de impuestos en un
momento de Gran inseguridad económica y
apostó por el contrario para implementar
medidas de alivio fiscal y consejo
asesor de pronóstico hoy que la economía
alemana caerá un 0,2% en 2023 y aseguró
que la inflación alcanzará en el 8% para
finalizar este año y pasamos a la cifra
del día para el cierre bueno Amazon es
la primera empresa en perder un billón
de dólares en el valor de Mercado La
capitalización de Mercado cayó a 878 mil
millones de dólares desde el 1,88
billones de dólares que había registrado
en su pico en 2021 Microsoft Word
también le sigue de cerca perdiendo
900 mil millones de dólares Muchas
gracias Jorge por esta actualización del
mundo de la economía a continuación en
directo América ya viene el debate
[Música]